let's move on to another state there is
Ohio and as you guys know JD Vance who's
been on the show Republican is running
against Tim Ryan Democrat and the debate
which was last week was it was I think a
real knockout for uh JD over Tim Ryan he
just really went at him we're seeing
Republicans who are finally just not
accepting the endless oh the narrative
is that we are just all racist bigots
we're actually going to fight back we're
not just going to take it anymore
here's exactly what happens when the
media and people like Tim Ryan accuse me
of engaging the grace great replacement
Theory you're pedaling it I'll tell you
exactly what happens Tim what happens is
that my own children my biracial
children get attacked by scumbags online
and in person because you are so
desperate for political power that
you'll accuse me the father of three
beautiful biracial babies of engaging in
racism we are sick of it you can believe
in a border without being a racist you
can believe in the the country without
being a racist and this just shows how
desperate this guy is for political
power I know you've been in office for
20 years Tim and I know it's a sweet gig
but you're so desperate not to have a
real job that you'll slander me and
slander my family it's disgraceful I hit
him back right like saying the truth uh
JD happens to be married to an Indian
woman so she is let's say of brown skin
and now Tim Tim Ryan obviously doesn't
care about that and and that's the point
these these attacks these oh you are
just a racist because you're a
republican you are just a bigot because
you want a border it ain't working
anymore and that's why they're getting
more hysterical that's why they're
always moving to this now democracy is
under threat because the cries of racism
really did fall flat and what they've
also done is they've done the boy who
cries wolf now when the real racists are
here when the real bigots get out there
and say and say awful things a lot of
people won't care